foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry its student population how
students are selected for the school and
how muggle bones are told that they're
magical since the 10th Century Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and was a tree
located in the Scottish Highlands has
been the premier destination for young
witches and wizards to learn magic at
least in that part of the world and
since the school was founded it's been
filled year after year with new batches
of promising young witches and wizards
over the centuries the school has
produced copious amounts of talented
Witch and Wizard alumni the finest
School of Witchcraft and was a Dre in
the world but my question is how are
these students chosen to attend this
famous Wizarding institution how do they
find out they've been chosen we know
they get an acceptance letter but who
decides that their name gets put on that
letter and how does this process differ
for mugglebones young witches and
wizards with no prior knowledge of the
vast Wizarding World students who come
from a magical background are most
likely already somewhat privy to
Hogwarts as it's likely that someone in
their family attended Hogwarts before
them this makes the delivery of their
acceptance letter less surprising
however the families of mugglebones
would have no concept of magic at all
I.E Hermione and that is why there are
different procedures for different types
of students but one thing that's
Universal for all students is how they
are chosen for the school enter the
quill of Acceptance in a small locked
Tower never visited by any student at
Hogwarts sits an ancient book that has
not been touched by human hands since
the four Founders placed it there on
completion of the castle beside the book
which is bound in peeling black
dragonhide stands a small silver ink pot
and from this protrudes along faded
quill these are the quill of acceptance
and the Book of admittance and they
constitute the only process by which
students are selected for Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry the
book and quill were put in place by the
founders of Hogwarts to Aid with and
automate the hog Court selection process
they knew that for centuries they would
need students to be selected for the
school and there's no way that they
would be able to manage it manually one
of the main parameters put in place for
detecting students is as follows at the
precise moment that a child first
exhibits signs of Magic the quill which
is believed to have been taken from an
augury who floats up out of its import
and attempts to inscribe the name of
that child upon the pages of the book
this means that as soon as a child shows
any form of magic it is immediately set
in writing that they are a magical being
no child would be able to perform magic
undetected without this magical book and
quill taking note of it and how exactly
this quill operates is anyone's guess if
anybody understands what powerful and
long-lasting Magic causes this book and
quill to behave as they do nobody has
ever confessed to it doubtless because
as Albus Dumbledore one side it saves
the staff tedious explanations to
parents who are Furious that their
children have not been selected for
Hogwarts the book and Quill's decision
is final and no child has ever been
admitted whose name is not first been
inscribed on the books yellowing pages
one thing that is worth mentioning
however is that sometimes the book and
the quill don't quite agree on what
constitutes magical activity a mere
whiff of magic suffices for the quill
the book however will often snapshot
refusing to be written upon until it
receives sufficiently dramatic evidence
of magical ability in the case of never
Longbottom for instance the quill was
eager to write his name in the book
right at his birth he came from a
magical family and exhibited faint signs
of magic right away but at the same time
no one really seemed to notice the book
included it wasn't until he was eight
years old and was able to survive a fool
that should have killed him that the
book finally accepted him the main
reason for the book sternness is to keep
out squibs non-magic children born to
witches and wizards occasionally have
some small residual Aura of magic about
them due to their parents but once their
parents magic has worn off them it
becomes clear that they will never have
the ability to perform spells the quill
sensitivity coupled with the book's
implacability have never yet made a
mistake with how these students are
chosen out of the way let's next look at
how the students themselves are notified
before students coming from a magical
family the first step is the Hogwarts
acceptance letter the Hogwarts
acceptance letter informs new students
of their acceptance to Hogwarts School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry and provided
along with the latter is a list of
required textbooks and materials
required for the upcoming school year
when a witch or wizard from a magical
family receives this letter things are
fairly straightforward when the time
comes for them to go to school they're
simply brought to platform nine and
three quarters and sent off the
procedure for mugglebones however is a
little bit different as I'm sure you can
imagine mailing a letter like that to a
muggle family without any context would
be undoubtedly viewed as some sort of
hoax or trick to remedy this Hogwarts
letters sent to muggleborn students are
hand delivered by a member of Staff the
books don't actually acknowledge which
staff member is directly responsible for
this however as McGonagall is in charge
of the registrar it makes most sense
that it would be her responsibility
impressive muggleborn students end up
with the same letter as everyone else
it's just how it's delivered that
differs by visiting it allows the staff
member to explain the unique nature of
their child's magical abilities as well
as provide the family with an
opportunity to ask questions I know I'd
have a few I can't even begin to imagine
how difficult it would be to explain
magic to a muggle a real monster of a
task however if it's going to be anyone
I think that either Dumbledore or
McGonagall would be most convincing
Hermione Granger discusses her reaction
to the news in the books nobody in my
family's magic at all it was ever such a
surprise when I got my letter but I was
ever so pleased of course I mean it's
the very best School of Witchcraft there
is I've heard I've learned all our
courses by heart of course I just hope
it will be enough I'm Hermione Granger
by the way who are you and so does
muggleborn Colin creevey it's amazing
here isn't it I never knew all the odd
stuff I could do was magic till I got
the letter from Hogwarts my dad's a
Milkman he couldn't believe it either so
I'm taking loads of pictures to send
home to him whether or not Hermione was
already cognizant of her magical
abilities before the Hogwarts staff
member visited is anyone's guess as this
greatly varies from student to student
even though Harry Potter hailed from a
Wizarding family he was raised by
Muggles which meant that the news was
just as shocking to him as it was to
Hermione we also know that Harry had his
fair share of unusual accidents before
ever finding out that he was a wizard
things like growing his hair back
quickly after unwanted haircuts and
talking to snakes things that were
simply not normal occurrences for a
muggle boy so did Armani have similar
things happen to her based on how the
quill of acceptance Works detecting
magic we can derive that she must have
performed some involuntary magic at one
point or another however whether she was
aware of it or not is a completely
different story and that's it for this
video If you enjoyed the content please
remember to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]